[Musique]
je
cet hippopotame vous l'aurez mettez dans
la nature où vous le reprenez à eau à
ces gens de cirque
il est mort comme il a été comme la lame
et amis de la famille kermiche et tout
ça ils sont bannis potable il ya des
grands grands containers pour
l'hippopotame cette bête est né avec eux
il est avec eux ils ont eu tout petit il
est habitué à ça comme ça une part
ailleurs
comme le malheur c'est scandaleux on
veut leur enlever les orques on veut
leur enlever les dauphins ces animaux
sont habitués à leur bassin ils sont nés
en captivité là bas et ils sont tous
gardé j'avais pas sur la disparition
dans le milieu naturel
le ils ont remis le seaworld clan kelly
fourni ou en floride je sais plus un
orque dans le milieu naturel parce que
ces associations protectrices animal on
dit ah non c'est pas normal qu'ils
soient dans des bassins mais ils l'ont
remis dans l'océan
il a même pas fait une semaine de vie
s'est fait couper en deux par la lutte
il voulait la mort de tous ces animaux
eric la question je voudrais vous poser
c'est ces cas de maltraitance ils
doivent être connus dans votre combat
est d'accord pour dénoncer voilà
pourquoi c'est moi je connais pas tout
le monde qui n'en et la maltraitance
dans notre métier c'est possible mais
pourquoi il n'y a pas une sorte de par
la police belge d'autorégulation de
votre profession j'entendais mon harley
ou quand vous êtes témoin ça moi j'ai
envie qu'on fasse le ménage et j'ai même
envie si on me le permet d'avoir une
petite place au milieu de nos autorités
de notre gouvernement pour justement
faire le ménage mais vous ne pourrez
peut-être sur le meilleur représentant
les bienvenus les aborder avec le
bienvenu dans ce qu'on arrive à temps
avant qu'on dise à quel prix musique et
aux rhumes un dresseur venez paru venez
prendre une part aux yeux du
gouvernement pour le bien-être animal
alors qu'on a tous et en effet d'irriter
dossier ce qui se passe les gants et ses
associations protectrices animal
federico ça je vous rencontre emmanuel
macron manuel frédéric je le sais ce qui
se passe en même temps et toi en tant
que professionnel c'étaient les images
ta bulle tu les as déjà vu sinon non non
non non ont foulé le système je sais
qu'il a raison il faut les dénoncer
l'hippopotame il est bien évident ne
l'aurait pas les autres à voir les uns
dans les autres je connais bien il n'est
pas bien ça s'est passé comme il n'est
pas dans des conditions ce titre est à
sa suis là si vous le reprenez vous
allez le tuer l'âme on peut pas on peut
pas on peut pas admettre des meubles
échelonner leurs hippopotames
il est estimé à la mort j'ai entendu
mais du coup qu'est ce qu'on qu'est ce
qu'on doit faire frédéric ce qu'on doit
faire c'est très simple qu'on laisse les
animaux aux gens de cirque qu'on les
empêche pas de pouvoir travailler avec
ce type en herman 12 est d'accord
écoutez moi on était d'accord et comme
vous rêvent d'un beaucoup moins
itinérante qui chialent un jour voir
moins de représentations pour avoir un
bien-être animal encore mieux pour les
animaux pour cet hippopotame qui est
itinérant qui à ce moment là pour rester
trois semaines à moi comme dans certains
parcs animaliers à ce moment-là sommes
allés dans les eaux et bien que le
gouvernement donne la possibilité qu'ils
aient des bassins énorme même en des
temps est inhérent à ce moment là et
qu'on fasse un bien-être et qu'on nous
qu'on aide pour le bien-être de cet
animal à celui là après si vous me dites
que l'hippopotame n'a peut-être pas une
part en itinérance comme ça et ben voilà
qu'on arrête l'itinérance pour les
hippopotames mais pas pour celui-là suis
là si vous l'arrêté sur l'itinérance
avec lui il est mort et les lions et les
tigres
c'est pareil comme les éléphants c'est
parce qu'on est habitué à l'itinérance
moi mais lyon
ils sont heureux de voir à chaque fois
je le quand j'ouvre les panneaux les
remorques des 32 de transport